ciao a tutti ragazzi e bentornato no
puntata no lasciamo stare i convenevoli
oggi non lo diciamo
sapete perché perché oggi ho la
soluzione che cos'era per tutti coloro
che hanno uno smisurato bisogno di
fregare esatto quindi andremo a creare
una ricetta fatta apposta per
rimorchiare restate connessi subito gli
ingredienti sigla del tonno fresco
guardate il bellissimo francio questo si
può mangiare e crudo e lo faremo voluto
peperoncino non ho trovato quello lungo
questo è leggermente più piccante lo
faremo provare dopo una cabina menta
basilico e pinoli
macché pinoli pistacchi agli amici
capperi online bellissimo che enrico s'è
perso superto d'atene di gianni
dolcissimi calamarata trafilata al
bronzo sale pepe olio
andiamo subito alla creazione del piatto
compete e dove no non ci permette più
chiediti dai lettori
ho detto bene dal default andiamo a
tagliare il tonno l'idea è avere sul
finale un tonno mezzo cotto e mezzo
minuto quindi facciamo tutte belle
strisce quando lo andrete a comprare
dovete chiedere il tono ha battuto se è
possibile poi mangiarlo con uno
altrimenti il pesce delle star minimo
quattro giorni in freezer
mi raccomando una volta tagliato tutto a
striscioline lo andremo a fare tutto a
cubetti non troppo piccoli che un
piacere poi sentiremo talbet una volta
vi chiedo di commentare il tonno andremo
a dividerlo a metà perché ne faremo una
meta cruda totalmente che con diremo poi
in una boule e l'altra metà andrà del
suddetto in cultura che va fatto ma uomo
tutta una boule utilizzerò questa bull
dove c'è la pasta tono dentro a voi non
lo sapete ma questa sera visto che
questa
una certa per rimorchiare io questa sera
ho chiamato una persona che vogliono
chiare si sono fidanzato ma voglio dire
lo faccio per voi tonno
andiamo subito ad aggiungere goccio
d'olio
abbiamo un ministro né cugino dello
sytrol e originale che ha avvelenato
guglielmo lo abbiamo un attimino a
modellare sul tavolo e inseriremo
all'interno prima tutto la gest leggera
leggera e non troppo aggressiva solo una
parte verde ok è poi anche qualche
goccia un taglio io vado a condire
provato a macerare perché questo già si
può mangiare con lui quindi qualche
goccia per dare un po di settore in più
a posto
basilico fresco e amano inseriamo tutti
i piccoli frammenti mamma mia ragazzi mi
sa che mi rimorchio da solo per fiera
che avrebbe seri molti amica rischio è
quello mentre un ciak era fresca ma come
potete vedere le luci l'hanno
completamente essiccata l'odore quello
che qui sono le foglie di mentuccia il
colpo non sta benissimo quando entrò io
ci avrei messo anche il verde del
cipollotto ma appunto visto che una
ricetta per rimorchiare
non possiamo mettere roba del genere
altrimenti perdite e sanno nella
politici si rovina totalmente la serata
pizzico di sale ma proprio leggerissimo
una cosa guardate qui ho un peperoncino
fresco si sa che al peperoncino è un
ingrediente molto afrodisiaco no perché
fa perché ti fa diventare durissimo il
braccio è un vasodilatatore è un po più
piccante dei soliti quindi non so quanto
sia piccante abbiamo fatto un test a una
gabbia dalla
maker ed eni qui da noi sputo anche
esposito che mi sta dando la schiena di
prendi questo che mastica dimmi il grado
di piccantezza non sono anche i semini e
nel frattempo io taglio è troppo forte
perché devo andare qui cito se e quando
avanti della perfetta spoiler mettono la
nostra cavia già detto il grado indica
attesa andremo a tagliare il peperoncino
a prendere solamente la buccia senza
semi facciamo nelle piccole striscioline
non troppo di carte ovviamente ottico
ricordiamo che il predator mostafa tutta
la fede la finzione perché lui non è
abituato proprio a mangiare piccante per
questo è stato scelto lui vado ha detto
cucchiaio e giriamo vito è caduto il
turno cazzo
ho creato il condimento che andrà poi a
caduto sopra la nostra camera quindi
immaginatevi la doppia consistenza torno
cotto con il datterino giallo e sopra
una bella cucchiano di questo mondo
crudo e volete dire che non riportiamo
faccio per voi
subito acqua sul fornello mi sono reso
conto assaggiando il turno che non è
così piccante il peperoncino come ci
dice che o il prezzo che cosa dobbiamo
quindi noi asseggiano nuovamente con
un'altra calda quindi enrico per la
patria
vieni qui vieni qui che la caravan tema
che è una roba simile
allora dammi va anche l'altro aia
spavaldo è sempre senza semi e uccidimi
secondo me la reazione del premier
faccia e alterata o che ne mette un
altro poco è arrivato tanto che vuol
dire sapere quanta loro hanno assaggiato
tutti il peperoncino
ma torniamo al cattivo tutti se no
magari una nova è tranquillo non lo
reggo abbastanza allora vanno reggina
facciamo entrare in macchina dalla porta
magica ma come ho visto un cazzo me ne
fa uno scherzo
no non è uno scherzo è una burla è tema
patria guardate la gara possa dire una
cosa
l'ostaggio pulire forte francesca yen i
puri di una loggia coperta di passaggio
pure io è l'altra metà a un decimo del
mio ragazzo male o gravissima pubblico
la reazione perché il limone e allora
non è forte però ovviamente quando uno
ingoia tutto il bocco all'interno di
resta quel prospetto con il trend del
laterino perché adesso andremo a creare
il sughetto che in padella
tra gli del pachino in quattro veda bene
ancora meno e subito lui il professorino
12 regali ma magari tutto col io e
l'obbligo a quello pagato buca ma la
settimana che verrà qui appoggiato
apertamente tutto queste sei stato
allestito per lei la cena ma per voi il
contesto ma per caso anche ma si vuole
assaggiare un po di leon cino è perciò
un motorino continuo dentro b e padella
aglio olio cappellini a ricette queste
si possono anche mangiare il nulla
[Musica]
andiamo a creare il nostro fondo di
cottura col braccio fine capperi
dissalati tutto insieme che ha portato
troviamo un altro a una cosa non è che
visto che voi scrivete sotto i commenti
l'era la maglietta di quadra
io devo stare qui elevare la maglietta
mi senti mercificare la cia non so che
devo fare con il balletto una cosa
comunque fa calvino non sono folli ed
altri non avevo ma non lo faccio perché
me l'avete chiesto tutto il modello olio
abbondante
ricordiamoci non vadano spese oggi
dobbiamo rimorchiarla ajo anche qui
niente cipolla lagnano lo criticavano lo
lasciamo in tempo perché lo leghiamo
quando dobbiamo avere una fiat ha di
quel della caverna porca miseria armate
siamo un momento quello quello netto e
poi abbiamo di pomodorino e cota è
caduto ma comunque veramente sono un po
emozionato per questa sera ai ha dentro
andiamo sul fuoco accendiamo
all'ingrosso sono qui
bucchi alla di legno presentiamo
sfrigolare qui in padella
i nostri colori per evitare di bruciare
il nostro soffritto inseriamo i
pomodorini butta la pasta
andiamo ad aggiungere il tonno un'altra
meta la prendiamo ed andiamo a votare
insieme fatti tagli estiva ieri da the
venetian di cottura rapida veloce a
fiamma alta ma la maturità dei filamenti
i nostri pistacchi girata alla nostra di
rasero
come sempre gli ultimi minuti di cottura
animale mi padella e soprattutto il
condimento vogliamo farci sentire al
telefono qualche finta telefonata
speriamo lario dalla padella
ricordatevi sempre quantistiche mettere
dentro il secondino pronto bellezza non
può più venire
aspetta un attimo ragazzi se le cose si
mettono male fatemi sentire il profumo
della pietanza si è come leggere
macchina o dopo semplice non veniamo di
cuocere da basta aiutiamoci sempre con
la nostra buonissima acqua di cottura
ragazzi siamo in dirittura d'arrivo la
parola importante il piatto ragazzi
potete anche servire ma dentro una
scarpa perché è il contenuto tutto a
terra ma ci arrendiamo 21 marzo
convenuto guardare che criminalistiche
di tanto che cosa si stacca un commento
la facciamo dire ad un altro che ci
siamo mai rimpianta mente un momento
confidenza perché non ho fatto perché è
una scena di re mida una persona ce la
faccio un primo no faccio antipastino
primo secondo no ci ha detto il primo
perché perché non ci arriva accedendo
mamma mia ragazzi non ti manca
quello che ci ha ordinato di ghiaccio
altri antico la nostra ghiacciando nella
mente
spegniamo la fiamma e guarda fuoco
andiamo a spadellare si mantenga signora
in patria tela che la musica di questo
piatto abbondante mescolata tonno crudo
è il momento e andiamo
ce n'è per finire spolverata di
pistacchio tritato giro d'olio basilico
metta affronti la scelta non possa dare
questo è il risultato finale cosa
dovremmo dire ce la faremo ma senza
intorno all'ora se non rimorchi così e
io ho capito che cosa intendeva ragazzi
stai tanto via via ieri aspettando
vengano sparite
a buongiorno ti stanno aspettando prego
entra accomodati ti faccio assaggiare i
piatti terremoto
ok ragazzi in questo momento alle mie
spalle ma non lo abbiate timore mai
sapete perché perché ci penserà lui la
ricetta del rimorchio
adesso andiamo a fare la prova del nove
seguitemi
eccoci qui questo è per te
mi sa proprio rimorchiato avete visto
siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
dimostrazione però per scontato no una
cosa sei maschio
potete chiamarlo col mio nome a un
ultima cosa non incrocia temi
[Musica]
[Risate]